we had Blake and Christina what we had a
goodbye to my so much and we had a hello
to Dean come back here this is your
bachelor in paradise episode 10 recap
grab your glasses
it's time for roses and rosy hi you guys
i'm lauren zima through the blanket a
different way today I usually throw it
that way today I threw it that way
because everything has gone upside down
in freaking paradise there's no time to
waste we might have to get to the Grand
Canyon so let's get to it what did you
guys think of this episode let me know
in the comments below but first of all
cuz we're gonna need it let's get
started with drinking responsibly
anyway drink for every time someone is
hanging out over the edge of the
infinity pool looking pensive mmm it's
like new is a good place to think the
edge of this pool staring off into
infinity
wondering about the infinite
possibilities of my love life
and whether I should jump or keep
swimming so we're starting off okay you
know drink for every beautiful couple
we have katieandchris Demi and Christian
and I guess JPJ and you know I'm here
for you and are they back on because
things are turning around and upside
down on this episode of paradise also
John Paul Jones doing a lot of toothpick
work not a good scene work in this
episode gross it's like fur good-looking
guys doing a lot of gross crap choking
and vomiting well he isn't picking his
teeth
hail john bob johnson Taoiseach are
talking you know like you know and she
needs him to trust her need you to trust
me can't do that and yes there are
plenty of fish in the sea but only John
Paul Jones can catch one with his bare
hands
what he ran to the sea and he grabbed a
fish from it I almost wondered if the
producers had planted a fish on the
beach how did he do that oh this man's a
mystery the only thing that's not
mysterious about John Ball Jones is that
he's unable to drink a liquid without
choking on it where's Mike doing
but you know who's not in a couple Mike
he's still here yeah and what's he doing
mostly handstands alone that's dark you
know it's like you can try to get up and
going but sometimes if you're alone you
fall over
I saw Mike and Angela spending a lot of
time together last night I don't have
romantic feelings for Angela and uh the
clay and Angela issue is still a thing I
can't take it anymore so I just want to
deliver a message to clay get over
yourself
okay okay yes you don't on the beach
Angela has every right to be here and
you're saying your concern about
Angela's presence is how it might
negatively affect you and Nicole's
relationship well guess what the only
reason it's affecting you too is because
it's affecting you you play Harbor seem
to be harboring some feelings about
Angela and so other people's feelings
are getting hurt and clay as much as you
workout in the sand that sand is turning
to dirt and I am done
speaking of in our feelings Blake for
the last couple episodes has been sad
Blake right like we had scary sad Blake
where we had to check on him and then we
just had kind of mopey Blake and now
we're getting desperate and maybe even
delusional Blake Blake says he has
realized that christina is the one
[Applause]
right there Christina
he's been right there in this little
time they had such casino
[Music]
this time
I don't believe this for a second
did you believe Blake do you think he's
really realized that christina is the
woman for him forever he's good chef I
think Blake wants a rose I don't know
why he wants to stay in paradise so
badly because it's going so poorly I
think he's lost lost the Blake and drink
every time Christina is the voice of the
people and the voice for herself she's
like why is going on
oh no I've just been I've been thinking
a lot
thinking a lot about what you why oh
that's good so cold I kind of hope
Christina turns cold to Blake that's
what she came here to paradise we're
right to put him in his place she wisely
tells Blake to sleep on it
talk to me tomorrow not sleep with it
[Music]
sleep on it
Blake make sure this is still what you
want to do not who you want it what you
want it do ya body language may not be
his first language I'm supposed to keep
laying it on a little more thick but
from sex just slow MacDonald is moving
at a glacial pace isn't he he still
won't kiss Sydney and I have to say to
Sydney girl maybe you in the words of
Sheryl Sandberg leaned in
I need a drink
I don't think that men always have to
make the moon I think women can show
their interest too
and Matt is obviously stressed drink
every time Matt is sweating also
profusely like I'm going to be thinking
about this betta sweat that's just
driving down my side of my face right
and it was it alright gosh is it just
the lights here is that what it is I'm
really sweating
Old MacDonald had a farm of sweat glands
luckily though we turned a bit on John
Paul Jones he does show what a good
friend he is in this moment can you do
me a huge favor bro he takes a towel
and wipes the sweat off Matt Donald's
back that did I got you bro and drink
for every muscle group that John Paul
Jones mentions and I didn't know hey
dude you got some great rhomboids didn't
rig traps course dude
but MacDonald and Sydney finally kissed
and this show is the gift that keeps on
giving because it gives us what we all
wanted literal applause and fire
oh my gosh my mom is gonna freakin kill
me but from there and what can I talk to
you oh so back to clams oh yeah clay
asks Angela if they can talk and she is
the voice of the people she says it's a
must
Angela can I talk to you
but actually I thought this conversation
was productive
did you let's just coexist I don't it
seemed to be the post-breakup
clear the air get closure I'm glad we
had this talk convo that clay and Angela
needed oh I can just solely focus on
chase and i's relationship so now Angela
is focused on chase McNary and I guess
that means her and Mike didn't want you
guys where are the answers on that what
is going on with Mike Mike I'm losing to
be connecting with people on a deep
enough level that they're gonna show us
how things end it does make me wonder
and I say this loving Mike but was Mike
thinking about being The Bachelor I'm
gonna get some hate for saying that I
don't know but I'm wondering I now in
this moment i'm so glad all that
happened
because we're sitting here right now we
do have a rose ceremony to get to and
Blake is talking to Christina you know
the one and he wants to be real with her
he is all in on you to the point of
loosely quoting When Harry Met Sally and
you realize what you you want in the
life you want
if you want to start immediately I came
here tonight because when you realize
you want to spend the rest of your life
with somebody
you want the rest of your life to start
as soon as possible so finally it's the
rose ceremony and Nicole gives a roast
of clay and tells him quote no one will
ever come to come between us that seemed
big didn't it I mean someone very much
almost just did it like Blake and
Christina trade roses again and Mike is
going home what did you guys think of
Mike not getting a rose he's still
smiling he's still being positive and I
do want to address the Batchelor
conversation a little bit more because I
had spoken to Mike both at the men tell
all and in a recent sit-down interview
and both times he told me he had not had
serious discussions about being the
bachelor and his prediction was that
Peter Webber would be named The Bachelor
now here's the thing about Mike if we're
just looking at making a TV show I was
very excited about the prospect of Mike
for bachelor back on Hannah Brown season
we've not seen a ton of emotion we've
not seen a ton of Mike and it does make
me wonder if when thinking about making
a TV show that became the issue
he's Mike's problem when it comes to
reality TV that he's just too happy let
me know in the comments below come on
bree is here remember Bree she was a
fake Australian no Australian accent
here today Bree seems built for Paradise
and I'm actually shocked that she didn't
show up sooner hey I will have a date
card
and the question is will Blake go on a
date with Bri Blake and greet break will
it break apart Blake and Christina the
strongest couple here we all know that
Bri wants to take Blake on this date
they were definitely hitting it off at
the wedding
that becomes the question will Blake be
true to his word
Christina seems stressed I think she's
crying I just need a moment you guys I'm
not sure I don't hear tears but her
voice dropped like ten octaves Christina
says the problem with Blake is that she
does believe him I believe when Blake
says something but it's like 99% 99%
it's just not that 1% is that 1% day
No hey what is that at least like Tim
let me know in the comments below just
want to tell you like I suppose through
that I'm not seeing anybody else down
here and I don't want to
but shears to Blake Blake makes a good
choice he doesn't go on the date with
Bri because he's all-in on Christina
interestingly she picks Matt and even
more interestingly Matt Donald has no
problem kissing Bri Oh
[Music]
Old MacDonald had a farm eiei ho Matt I
thought you were so worried about what
your mom was gonna thank my mom he's
gonna freakin kill me if I'm like making
out with Jegs
very interesting old mom Donald's might
not be too happy with that much but from
Matt Donald Judy
[Music]
no Dean is back but you know it's not
back his mustache the mustache is gone
and I'm wondering if I was wrong I
thought the mustache represented growth
but maybe it didn't maybe the mustache
represented a mask
Dean hiding from becoming his true growl
self and maybe the growth is really
about the long hair because the long
hair still there okay
so Dean is back and do you guys think
that he has changed let me know in the
comments below I would not say I'm happy
to see Dean I'm still quit Matty broke
up with Kaelyn on her birthday you know
who else is not happy to see Dean Connor
dies here
Connor is like dude go back to hear that
go back here it's our to grasp Conners
anger through that voice go back here
look dude I hate you I hate you back to
the bone why does he think he can leave
her like that and come back here so Dean
has descended into paradise again and of
course he grabs Kailyn and they go to
talk oh he's just kind of tried to keep
you out like an arm's length I think for
my own sake of self-preservation
he explains where he's been and I flew
back to San Diego more like van Diego am
i right and then he said run to the car
to the Grand Canyon for like Grand
Banyan I thought about how
badly that I wish that you were there
with me and he says he missed Kalyan I
mean Kayvan the whole time and claims
that now he wants a relationship I
wanted us to try and be in a
relationship
Kalyan seems trepidatious rightfully so
Kaitlyn says Connor has been easy on her
game down and we've been trying to
explore thing
and Dean's like who wants easy nice
don't underestimate easy our
relationships easy
no but should they be hard No
so maybe Dean's should get in the van
and go but the Vans not here Rana Beach
Dean is here though and would you guys
take Dean back let me know in the
comments below and then whoa whoa whoa I
came here to ask you if that you would
leave paradise with me today Dean wants
Kalyn to go he asks her to leave
paradise with him today why Christian
State does he have to get back to the
van is it parked illegally is it at the
airport those overnight rates are big
does it really have the dangerous guy
and the perfect man so Kalyn says I have
a dangerous guy and a perfect man what
do I do
and that question shouldn't be hard one
to answer but for us the audience the
answer is you leave us on a cliffhanger
of course in this case the cliff were
hanging off of is the Grand Canyon and I
guess we'll have to wait and find out
next week whether we drive the van off
and over it like Thelma and Louise where
we just sit on the edge and look out and
take a good picture on our iPhones and
have a nice GD day all right everybody
what an episode of bachelor in paradise
of course tell me what you guys thought
and if you want a personal message from
me I'm on cameo and I still have a lot
of wine left which is weird for me and
also the Kaelyn Deane thing really
stressed me out so here we go please
drink responsibly I love you guys so
much thank you for watching we will be
back next week until then take it easy
bye
[Music]